Foundation models are large AI models
that can be adapted to a wide range of
tasks and can generate high quality
output Foundation models are multitask
rather than single task One Foundation
model can perform a wide array of tasks
out of the box such as summarization
question and answering classification
these models are typically trained on
vast amounts of diverse data allowing
them to learn General patterns and
representations that can be applied
across various domains and tasks and
with no or minimal training required
Foundation models can work well out of
the box and can be adapted for targeted
use cases with very little example data
Google's curated set a foundation models
available through the model garden and
vertex AI enables you to quickly find
and customize the right model for your
task